hey everybody welcome to the podcast
we're back with another episode of roll
on our ask me anything
format where me and my height man Adam
Adam Skolnick a break down a couple
topics we take questions from the
listeners and the idea is just to be a
little bit more contemporaneous and
freeform with this show so Adam how's it
going it's going good man I've had it's
been a crazy it's been a crazy last
couple of weeks mmm yeah well you moved
moved we moved in the same building to a
slightly bigger place because you know
my wife is eight months pregnant almost
where I guess it's seven months and
through the seventh we're in the eighth
month now and so we moved to this place
that is like so similar the old place
but just like slightly different like
your mind your breathing yeah so your
mind is like a skipped record usually
when you move you want to move to a
radically different place it's like
easier to process but in this case it's
like slightly different so it was very
it's like a trick mirror we're living in
a trick mirror well like a parallel
universe we're living in a parallel
universe well you're here today here
we're gonna break it down before we get
into it I did want to make a couple
announcements big announcements I'm very
excited about I have been hard at work
for the last several weeks trying to put
the finishing touches on a new book it's
been a while since right yeah so super
excited about it it's called voicing
change and essentially it's a beautiful
coffee table art book that contains
timeless wisdom from a podcast with
layouts and excerpts from some of my
favorite guests over the years and
company buy beautiful photographs and
I'm so excited about it super proud how
many interviews object we're trying to
figure out right now how many like we we
have of course like I can't put
everybody in and this will probably be
the first in what will be
a number of volumes because we've kind
of got this down and we could put one
out potentially every year so this is
just to be considered like the first one
and of course no matter how well I try
to curate it I'm sure I'll leave
somebody's favorite guest but right now
I think we have about 50 excerpts in
there with some essays that a few people
have contributed and it's going to be
great we don't have an official release
date yet but we're looking at around
Thanksgiving time hopefully don't hang
upon printers and all of that so you're
self publishing this one we are self
publishing this one yeah congrats man
and it's looking really beautiful can't
wait to share more about it but this
you've been writing and I've said
anything on the podcast about it
but that's what I've been basically
spending most of my time doing lately
yeah you said you've been writing like
ten hours a day or like holed up into
that well in in the office yeah but the
problem is that I spent the better part
of the the quarantine complete
dilettante until the deadline was just
so overwhelming that I was put into a
situation where I had to drop everything
that I was doing and only write and for
whatever reason what it is man like it
took that deadline and the fear of not
having it done to get my ass in gear and
get this thing finished
that's what deadlines do oh I wish I
could be the person who just works on it
two hours a day but how long has it been
since you've been like writing that
intensively like long time a long time
you know the first book the last book
book that I did was finding all truths
right years ago right I rewrote it a
couple years ago but still you know that
wasn't like creating a book out of a
whole whole cloth the cookbooks are more
like this project in that they're jigsaw
puzzles where there's a lot of people
involved like I have a whole team of
people who are working on this so
there's only aspects of it that are the
written word a lot of it is design and
layout and all the like and curating you
know how we want it to be presented but
but you know I've done a fair amount of
writing because I so I'm excited about
it yeah
it's exciting I can that back in the
writing mode forget the first time in a
long time
you got the muscle you warmed up do you
find that like as you've started getting
back into it that you're finally finding
a flow or that you find a flow or is it
always is it always hard like how is
that process for you well what's
interesting about that is I actually
have have really had a hard time getting
back into it and for whatever reason
like I hate the word you know writer's
block but for reasons unbeknownst to me
it has been quite a challenge to just
put my butt in the chair and do the
thing in a way that I haven't
experienced before in my life and I was
starting to get concerned like maybe I
just did not into doing this anymore or
maybe I've lost my touch or maybe I'm
getting old and I had a discussion on
the podcast with a neuroscientist
recently his guy Andrew Huber man who's
all about like how the brain works and I
laid this out for him I was like what is
wrong with me because then once the
deadline became real and I was able to
like appreciate the gravity of the
situation I created for myself and
started working on it now it's all I can
think about like everything else is a
distraction mmm I don't want to do
anything but do this and it made me
think like why you know why am i wired
in this way like the apps that's part of
my addictive nature because again I'd
like to be the person who just does it
in a very balanced manner but it's an
immersive experience you know yeah
somebody who writes books all the time
and is writing a book right now you know
you're in you're like all in and it
becomes your entire universe but I find
it's always hard you know like I just
finished the finally finished the first
draft of this raw this Roger I call it
and called the first draft of the raw
draft of this manuscript of this talking
about it's novel it's a novel it's like
talk about impostor syndrome I've had
that the entire time like you know like
because I did write a novel before and
that's what got me an agent but we
didn't sell it and but this time it's
not even nothing about my life it's not
so my autograph
that one was so it's it's it's it's
challenged me in ways and it was hot I
was also avoiding it I always had these
reasons why I shouldn't start it you
know like I didn't have the research
done I didn't have time to do it because
of this that the other thing and then
when quarantine Kamath in France and
exactly and then there's that well I
know I'm not Jonathan Franzen don't
worry spoiler alert but yeah so finally
getting that done but like each almost
every day finally towards the end once
you get to the point you can see the
downhill to the finish line
it becomes a little easier but like it
was hard almost every day and what
helped me was that Stephen King
interview with in the New York Times
Magazine David Marchese is it March s
and March they said you know he does
he's great
I think he's the best interviewer in
print media and he should be in New York
Magazine now he's at the Times Magazine
and Stephen King was he asked him is
does it always do you know when you have
like a great book on your hands when
you're writing goes they always feel
terrible yeah and if that's Stephen King
saying that very comforting it's very it
is very correcting yeah yeah yeah I'm
trying to get Stephen Pressfield on the
podcast
have you read war of art no turning pro
oh my goodness those are the manuals for
unlocking all of this stuff yeah yeah
yeah you should definitely check that I
think I need to he's the dude when it
comes to that stuff and he lives in
Malibu I've been going back and forth of
them oh really oh you'll get him on the
show so yeah yeah that's perfect the
other the other announcement that I
wanted to make is that we're right now
contemplating some version of a
subscription service for the things that
that we do here and I put a survey up on
the Facebook group page for the podcast
so for those of you don't know there's a
Facebook group which roll podcast you
can find it on on Facebook I'll put a
link in the show notes to that with a
few questions because it's something
that we're putting a lot of thought into
and if and how we do it is going to be
very much dependent upon all of your
feedback and input I don't want to do
anything that that isn't going to
you know satisfy the kind of things that
the audience is looking for from me so
excited about the work that we're doing
there the idea would be that we would be
able to offer some premium things beyond
just the podcasts will always be free
well I'm always going to do the podcast
the way that we're doing it but what
else can I do to be of service and
contribute to this community and how can
I be a more present communicative member
of the community as well mm-hmm which is
where my head's at
so if kind of like a remote retreat like
doing what you do in the retreat mode
but yeah how about a monthly zoom call
with everybody who's a subscriber what
about a bonus podcast episode every
month you know things like that mm-hmm
and just taking everybody's temperature
and pulse on on what they would be
interested in so excited about the work
that we're doing there and again that's
another thing where I'll keep you guys
posted and more will be revealed that
Facebook group is cool like it's fun to
see everybody interacting and connecting
on their own terms but with content
inspired by your content yeah I mean the
idea there is I wanted to make a place
for the community to do its own thing
outside of myself like for it for those
people to interact with each other and
to be able to see that happening is
really cool
yeah what's funny is after I had Doug
Evans on the podcast then it just became
like a whole portal for people sharing
about sprouting and everybody was you
know exchanging their tips and where
they get their equipment and what their
sprouts look like so I thought I would
bring in some of my own sprouts the
funny thing about that is Doug got me
doing it I got these canisters which you
can see here if you're watching this on
YouTube they're just basic glass I think
I got everything from sprout man sprout
man calm they have a little grated top
on them and I have now more sprouts than
I can possibly do anything with it I
literally had to stop sprouting because
they started to overwhelm much much too
much eating sprouts all day long did you
evict you from the kitchen no she's
excited about it actually because I've
taken an
interest in some version of home
economics change so she's very
supportive but I got a whole rack up in
our kitchen and I've got a process yeah
I'm it's very satisfying mmm because
it's all done it's also its first of all
it's super easy
you basically rinse these things
overnight and then you or you soak them
overnight and then you rinse them like
two or three times a day for a couple
days and they just do their thing
these are lentils so these are yeah
those are lentils here this one's like a
mix I got these like containers that pop
lids on them and I put them in the
fridge and weight loss tip he's for
anybody out there who's looking to drop
a few pounds Doug told me that he
basically just eats sprouts all day mmm
I was like how is that possible like
yeah aren't you starving like aren't you
crazy oh my god so I thought well I'll
try that so for the past couple weeks
like throughout the day I'll just munch
on sprouts as a snack and they're
actually incredibly filling mm-hmm you
can only eat so many where you max out
and my gut definitely had to adjust it
took a little bit that sounds now I'm
pretty adjusted and it's become habitual
like I'll just eat sprouts throughout
the day yeah and it really does modulate
my appetite and I'll eat a normal dinner
but there's been days where I'll just
eat sprouts during the day and then I'll
eat dinner and I've been fine so you are
like going in the full transition to
bunny I feel like it yeah run through
the hill anyway so yeah I'm enjoying it
though so you gotta get on it you know
April really wants to when you're
pregnant you can't eat sprouts I'm sure
it's in one of the baby books I've
avoided reading so far but all different
kinds of sprouts yeah they say stay away
from sprouts but that might be sprouts
you buying the kit in the in the store
because eco lies somehow more prevalent
in sprouts so I think if you make it
yourself maybe that's not as much of an
issue I think the fear rumors I don't
know but but I suspect the fear is that
you know they can go bad and if you eat
a bad patch that could be problematic or
dangerous yes I don't know that there
would be anything in sprouts that
haven't like
turned that would be unhealthy for a
pregnant person but I'm not a doctor
don't listen to me don't worry we're
sticking to the baby books we've got day
where you just were installing blinds in
the new place and they can't you can't
have the cords got to be cordless which
is elevated everything price-wise about
2 X uh-huh because and yesterday we're
talking about it like well maybe we
could just go with cords and she's like
I'm like what where does it say that we
shouldn't have cords he/she goes
literally every baby book oh really
and I'm like only one month until well
too so September 10 yeah yeah coming up
quick I think it's gonna be September
11th because I'm December 7th yeah I
think we're gonna be the tragic
holidaying boys we'll see you know more
will be revealed what do you want to
talk about her I I thought we could talk
a little bit about well let me set the
stage so as many of you know the last
couple months of the podcast have been
pretty heavy I've done my best to tackle
some very serious subjects everything
from racial injustice to systemic racism
food injustice you know really the most
pertinent important topics of our time
that we're grappling with we have a bit
of a respite this week I put up Kevin
Smith and his daughter Harley Quinn
Smith super delightful fun conversation
but I've been spending a lot of time
kind of reflecting on you know how to
best communicate and advocate in this
space with the understanding that it's
so fraught and because we put these
podcasts up on YouTube you see the
comments and you get a sense of what's
landing for people and what isn't not
that YouTube comments are a reliable
source so of constructive feedback but I
do know that for a lot of people it's
been challenging in terms of how to
communicate publicly in the most
effective way around these issues and
there's a lot of fear from certain
people
who don't want to get it wrong don't
want to misstep don't want to offend and
the result of that has been to retreat
from the conversation altogether which
doesn't help no right and you've decided
obviously against that from the
beginning you were very clear that you
wanted to address the situation in the
beginning what do you think is the
inspiration to retreat from it what are
people besides just fear is that is it
the idea of being cancelled or like
somehow being called out yeah I mean
there's a lot of calling out right now
there is a robust cancel culture of foot
and I think people are terrified of
getting a taste of what that experience
might be and look it's complicated
because on the one hand the the you know
the public forum is holding people
accountable for things that need to be
addressed and spoken about and in many
ways that culture has led to some of the
changes that we're seeing right now at
the same time I think it's important to
provide people a little bit of breathing
room around this who might get it wrong
initially you know Bill Maher talked
about this and it's closing monologue a
couple weeks ago that you know we have
to encourage people to participate in
this rather than discourage them from
raising their hand and saying you know I
want to be part of this as well but I'm
afraid mm-hmm I mean I think I agree
with you I mean there's there is a
danger of you don't want to become the
new McCarthy I queried a certain way and
and you're out um you know because that
plays into people who want to keep
things the same as they've always been
it plays right into their hands right
because now you've elevated them as the
people who are more in touch with free
speech which is you know definitely an
element to this cut of this country
that's been you know that's of all the
things I mean I'm of all the things
America has been good at free
Beach is one of them and it really is so
so it's probably at the top of that list
so it's it's its core to the culture
here mm-hmm that's why people like
coming here you know look what's
happening in Hong Kong right now we're
all overnight that rice gets the light
switch is turned off so when you cancel
people to the degree you know based on
there's some things that happen that are
legit but when you just cancel people
because they said something the wrong
way or all of a sudden that you know
things and and and their whole careers
is now in jeopardy especially if it's
really a misinterpretation or a matter
of perception that is dangerous because
you are playing you are pushing people
away that could be a contributor to
making things better mm-hmm
yeah and I think it's more nuanced than
just cancel culture it's just being
reprimanded publicly you know the way
Bill Maher put it he's like you want to
be a good ally but not too good or
you're a white Savior you want to use
your voice but you shouldn't make it
about yourself you know the rules are
complicated and it's almost like you
have to thread a needle or walk this
tightrope hmm and I think a lot of
people are just like I don't like I'm no
matter what I do it's not gonna be right
and so I'm just gonna opt out yeah and I
agree I mean like there is the argument
to be made that we wouldn't be where we
are in terms of confronting racism
finally and more definitively if it
wasn't for the orthodoxy of the left
right so now the fact that there are
hard lines of how to behave which are
kind of an F mud to people of my
generation Gen X which was like we we
wanted to rebel against those rules all
the time like when you were supposed to
behave a certain way we wanted to behave
a different way right but now this
generation is all about behaving the
right way and signaling the right things
and communicating the right way and and
so that has gotten us to this point
where we're actually making some
progress or it seems to we seems to me
that we're making some progress because
because people are holding politicians
feet to the fire and and other public
people you know people who have a public
platform
their feet are being held in the fire or
there they're stepping in line because
they want to whatever it is there is a
line mmm people are lined up to do it
and so it could be this orthodoxy which
can be construed as as somewhat
dangerous if if it continues going
forward like six moves down the road for
now has put us in a presidental position
in terms of tackling racism in America
and keep wanting it head-on so it's
there's that but then there's also the
thing is well if you continue to narrow
it then then are we gonna make the real
progress we want to make or should we
widen it and allow everybody to be a
part of it right
well the strictures have become so
constrained yeah and as a fellow gen-xer
yes you know it is true it was all about
individualism a rebellion against
control systems but the locus of that
control was always governments and
organizations whereas now the control
mechanism is diffused across the
population and to the extent that there
is value in woek 'no speaking up this
awareness inside of ourselves about
grander problems that exist outside of
our you know individualistic
dispositions at the same time the
extremist aspect of woke nests I think
is is very toxic and the downstream
implications of that type of policing of
speech and behavior is not in service to
the best interests of liberalism right
because liberalism is this ideal that we
want to aspire to where it can be people
of different thoughts and beliefs come
together to create a society that is
mostly free and open right right right
and when and and and when we're being
regimented in in such a way that
openness is called into question yeah
you know and and I think by it also or
who want to keep the status quo well
also the the the the extreme aspects
oakna Saul so just further entrench and
solidify the the conservative point of
view because people look at that and
just think these people are out of their
minds it's absolutely true also it now
like the new punk rock thing to do is to
be conservative so there's that aspect
to like if you won't really want to piss
people off you become you know that's
true like young people who want to piss
people off and be the radical now he's
like when we were growing up no way we
wouldn't be Republicans doing that right
now it is Republicans doing that beyond
that
the true heterodoxy is happening online
that's not a part of the mainstream
media or news culture that were that
we're seeing on cable news right the
ideas that are trying to address these
from a perspective of greater nuance and
understanding are happening in long-form
conversations you know across podcasting
in YouTube yeah agreed but it's it's
almost like both are happening and you
know that lets that gets us into this
other kind of place I mean I want before
we go in there but before we get into
kind of the wellness and and rabbit hole
and all that kind of to get us there
when I think about when I think of the
canceled culture and public shaming and
and the orthodoxy of speech and and and
political thought on the left and the
right I think of kind of the Balinese
philosophy of tree hit to Khurana which
is all about cultivating harmony with
yourself and with God or the universe
however you want to describe it harmony
among people within the community in the
family and harmony with nature in the
environment that's what it was all built
around because it was this culture that
came up on this small island is its own
kind of Hindu culture that developed
with animist beliefs and Hinduism and
the and this culture developed because
all we have is this island so we need to
make sure it all works you know like the
way we channel the water to the rice
fields everything the way we interact
with one another we are now in this
place where we want to eradicate and
destroy and I understand why you know
like it's because people have felt that
they
trying that their lives are in jeopardy
that they're being eradicated or not
heard or destroyed and attempted to
destroy but shouldn't the aspiration be
harmony you know like and and within
Balinese worldview is this idea that you
can't you can't destroy the the dark
thing the evil thing you can never be
destroyed the best you can do is
cultivate enough light that you have a
balance and that's what you can do and
that's not just within society that's
within yourself because we all have kind
of these dark thoughts right I mean
that's just part of the human condition
and so they do it through meditation and
through rituals that are performed on a
daily basis and then within a village
and and within island-wide but we it's
it's something that I think about I was
been thinking about that this week it
that would be a good place to get to if
we can consider how do we cultivate
harmony with ourselves within the
community and and with nature because
that should that should be the driving
force mm-hmm and if you do that there
will be no place for people like the
current president door you know
all right figures there will be no place
for them that they'll exist because you
can't eliminate that but you can't they
won't have the oxygen but when you do
this other thing where you try to
eradicate them they become like
demagogues they become bigger yeah not
smaller well I think the problem with I
mean it's a beautiful ideal I think the
what makes translating that notion or
laying that template upon America as we
see it right now is the fact that we we
we have systems that need to be reformed
yet before that's functional because
that idea as beautiful as it is gets
conflated with all lives matter or you
know I don't see color
you know what I mean like it's like Oh
harmony and I think in order to get to
that place first we need to drill down
on the the the systemic aspect of these
problems and what's driving you know the
the kind of unconscious forces that are
creating problems that lead to the
disenfranchisement of people of color
right and
until we do that we can't deal with the
harmony part No
so that's the sides like so do you want
the orthodoxy because that'll get which
which is the place that gets us there
though like the orthodoxy has got us
this place where we're confronting it
head on is that going to be enough to
actually get to the systemic root of it
or do you need to build consensus and if
you need to build consensus then you
can't do that with just the orthodoxy
right right so you need that yeah now I
understand yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean
you know consensus is the way forward
right but right now we're creating
demagogues yeah yeah my fear is that my
fear is that this polarization is only
gonna escalate and that really is
driving a rift that makes this problem
all the more difficult to solve right
and and and if you come across I mean
I'm I'm with the conversation of
systemic change and we need to get there
but if we if if what drives us towards
getting there is this idea of we we have
to live in harmony because we do live
here and we need a unity of purpose
around this so it's not so much trying
to culturally appropriate the polities
worldview and put it here it's the side
guiding life kind of like this idea that
that there is something to be learned
from all these different cultures that
have cultivated something that does seem
to work for people and for community
there's I mean not that it's an ideal
place but it's a it's it's something to
think about like a philosophy to think
about and how can that be applied here
yeah shifting gears a little bit I
wanted to talk about how all of these
ideas impact the Wellness and
alternative health community because one
of the things that I've noticed that I
think is super interesting is the way in
which the Wellness community itself has
become a certain aspect of it has become
radicalized or prone to more conspiracy
oriented ideas and I've been spending a
lot of time thinking about why that is
like there's a strange Venn diagram when
you look at the Wellness community and
how it overlaps with certain political
ideologies I used to think that these
things lived in separate universes but
now everything is political
and recent events have made that truth
all the more so and in thinking about it
the conclusion that I'm that I'm
arriving at is that I think I think at
its origins wellness welna the Wellness
movement if there is such a thing
grew out of the roots of alternative
health ideologies and those notions are
the result of people taking attempting
to take better control of their own
health trajectories and also a healthy
distrust of the medical establishment
like don't just you know go to your
doctor and get a prescription like here
are some other things that you could
potentially do that might make you a
healthier human being and over time I
think that bred a healthy distrust of
certain institutions that perhaps don't
have the best interests right
individuals and the patients and I think
that's good and now that seems to have
metastasized in ways that are
potentially unhealthy yeah it's like
embedded within this kind of wellness
community that is is becoming more and
more skeptical of things and especially
with this pandemic and and the CDC and
all you know that kind of thing that
you're talking about right and wellness
is that what you're getting at the fact
that online there's a healthy portion of
the wellness community that is basically
doesn't believe the coronavirus stats
doesn't believe that it's as dangerous
or yeah I don't want to go down some you
know crazy rabbit hole about conspiracy
X Y or Z because that's not the purpose
of why I brought this up but I think in
general yes like the there's a there's a
receptivity to potentially wrongheaded
ideas right now among the wellness
community that I think is new and
different and something to be aware of I
think that it comes it's because it's
because they've been you know all of
this stuff that we are seeing now fake
news
whether it be from the health side or
just general fake political news or
whatever it is that only works because
there was a period of time when we were
lied to and blatantly misled by the FBI
by government institutions by Dow
Chemical or whatever it is I don't know
if you saw the movie dark waters what
about the whole Teflon situation would I
think it's DuPont actually that Mark
Ruffalo movie I haven't seen it yeah but
I'm familiar with the case yeah yeah so
I mean there is this route that that is
kind of talks it was toxic to pee and
there's a healthy distrust that comes
with that whether it's a chemical
company or a pharmaceutical company or
an oil company and and so this is all a
result of that you know like in the 50s
when Village Voice was founded and then
all these all weeklies in the 60s kind
of and which was heavily tied in with
wellness stuff some of them were were
you know very much connected kind of
they popped up all across the country
these all weeklies and became a movement
and that was because the mainstream
media wasn't to be trusted they were
kind of spinning the party line that's
not you know so that that's hasn't
changed that that distrust of these
institutions never left now it's just
changed shape and form and into a much
more powerful force which is which is
digital media and social media yeah it
is weird that everything is political
now yeah there used to be politics and
everything else but now there's nothing
that isn't part and parcel of a
political discussion it is weird I don't
know whether that's good or bad
but I feel like it's not bringing us
together no I think it's serving to
really create distance between ourselves
and our fellow man it's dissonant yeah
no question and I don't know what the
way forward is I'm a free speech
proponent yeah but I think there's also
a responsibility that comes with having
a platform and I spend a lot of time
thinking about what are the kind of
conversations I want to have who are the
kind of people that I want sitting
across from me and it's not just anybody
like I put thought into that because
people are paying attention
listening they're watching and when I
see others shirk that responsibility for
the sake of views or clicks I think that
that that that is you're responsible
right now especially in a time that's so
fraught my hope is that everybody would
be mindful of the types of conversations
they're having and I don't think it's
enough to just say well I'm just I'm
just having a conversation with somebody
it doesn't mean that I agree with them
of course I've done hundreds of
interviews I'm not gonna agree with
everything that the person sitting
across from me says there's gonna be
healthy disagreement but I think that's
different that's entirely different from
having somebody on who's coming from a
you know a perspective that might get a
lot of attention but is potentially
harmful especially in a moment where
lives are truly at stake yeah and you're
in charge of your platform and you can
make those decisions and but what
happens when those are when it's more
systemic than that when it's an AI that
is teeing up video after video to people
right like well that's definitely what's
happening right so if you be you're one
of the people that is that cares about
their platform for your own personal you
know because you have a brand to protect
and you have a you have your own
motivations for that which are personal
but also from a perspective of running
your operation but when other people who
just want the clicks because it's easier
money more listeners that kind of thing
then they become part of a pile that an
algorithm or an AI right kind of starts
queuing up like its own DJ you know like
like that's a different thing entirely
you know right now which which really
brings us to the next thing that we
wanted to talk about yeah which is this
incredible podcast series that the New
York Times put out called rabbit hole
mm-hmm and I think to preface that
conversation I would say that we all
want to believe that we are not only
rational
sentient actors but that were not that
manipulatable right right yeah and when
you listen to this series you realize
just how inaccurate that actually is
yeah yeah yeah and it and it speaks
specifically and directly to the
statement that you just said so Adam and
I talked and we thought wouldn't be fun
on the show to do a little bit of you
know Show and Tell I brought the sprouts
but also share a few things that we've
been enjoying and the first thing that
came to my mind was this podcast series
because it had I thought it was superbly
done and speaks to exactly what we've
been talking about which i think is a
really important issue right now the
manner in which people are so easily
[Music]
swayed by the vicissitudes of the
YouTube algorithm yes I listen to this
like a couple months ago so it's not as
fresh in my mind as it is for you
because you just listen to it I just
listen to it
well Kevin Roos is the host and the
reporter behind it you know he's one of
New York Times best tech reporters and
he covers Facebook and social media
relentlessly and really is illuminated
many things for me before I started
listening to this podcast but mostly
I've been watching his posts like he
does either daily or weekly posts of the
most the most viewed most shared things
and nine out of ten of them are really
conservative
articles and one is like an Occupy
Democrats article so it's very political
it just shows you how stark and
political Facebook truly is and he kind
of raised that for me a while ago with
his reporting this is really interesting
because it shows you you know when he
interviews the CEO of YouTube and other
people involved it's almost like they're
surprised like they've unleashed this AI
which is the algorithm which operates on
its own and it queues up video after
video for people like it the podcast
opens if you haven't heard it it opens
with someone who has been kind of down
the rabbit hole I forgot his name but he
starts he starts watching
Joe Rogan which leads to Sebastian melon
oh I think is his name no Stefan Stefan
Stefan Molyneux only because his name
yeah
so yeah it basically tracks this one
young man's trajectory from an average
dude and how he becomes over time
radicalized by virtue of YouTube and
then ultimately how he finds his way out
of that rabbit also by virtue of you -
yeah and they they track they go through
his entire watch history yeah and they
look at all the videos that were
suggested to him and you can see this
like path this guy takes from one video
to the next to the next to the next how
it it walks him through this process of
ideation where he slowly becomes
immersed in ideas that are not his own
you know that he didn't necessarily
choose and by virtue of that
suggested column on the right hand side
of YouTube he ends up watching and how
incredibly influential all of that
became for that young man because they
spent hours what he spent hours watching
ya watching this stuff and that's the
other thing is you you keep hearing and
there's at the end of it there's a story
about pizza gate and an older youtube
addict I guess you could call it or a
door devotee who literally spent hat was
going through a hard time in her life
and basically YouTube was the one
comfort she had and she would just watch
hours of it in a row and she started
with Elizabeth Warren speeches right and
on territory yes you know so it shows
you so a couple things take away from me
is like I'm thinking I'd like to see a
study on AI and the YouTube algorithm
and what kind of hormones are going
through the body like I want I want some
science and that's media scientist to
like put someone in the UCLA like Nieman
lab put electrodes on their bodies and
literally find out what hormones are
being secreted in the person by this AI
well there are some interesting studies
that are being done right now there's
got call Tristan Harris who I believe is
a former Google executive
memory serves me who started now a
foundation that's that's looking at that
very thing is that what kind of research
specifically they're doing but there are
very smart people who are paying
attention to this because it really is
like getting played like who's the real
tool now like who's getting played right
and the irony in that of course is that
the messaging is all about how you need
to sort of take the red pill and emerge
from being play yes but in turn you are
actually yourself playing into something
else entirely it's this it's this
interesting kind of dichotomy looking on
the left where it used to be like
Twitter was this place where liberal
rage went to live and thrive and
progressives kind of had their say but
really everyone wondered will you what
are you really doing you're just
tweeting and YouTube it's like these
would be quote researchers they really
think of themselves as researchers lucky
in Florida that meeting over the mass
did you see that we're like a bunch of
angry people came up and was we're
chastising the City Council saying I
won't wear your met this mask is gonna
kill me like all sorts of crazy right it
and they described them so I've done my
research the research is watching
YouTube yes I mean I'm not [ __ ]
around like that right I think research
is like watching YouTube videos like you
hear that it's like I mean that is
that's scary yeah yeah you didn't know
that no I didn't know that researchers
know your I did see the woman who went
into Target and pulled all the masks off
that they were selling and threw them
all on the floor and yeah got angry it
wasn't she wasn't mad that she was being
forced to wear a mask she was mad that
target was selling masks because is the
repressed rage that so many people are
feeling right now
that has nothing to do with masks no it
has everything to do with something else
deeper what do you think it has to do
with because I was talking about this
was April like like like to have a
society that's reacting this way to the
pandemic and and and needs YouTube in
this manner and and and is craving this
kind of information it points to kind of
a raw at the
doesn't it I think it's
disenfranchisement disenfranchisement
and powerlessness like if you what what
would motivate you to go into a target
and like knock down a display case of
products on it unless something was
fundamentally broken inside of you and I
think people feel like they don't have a
voice and their lives are neutered in
such a way that that they're under
expressed I guess is a way to put it
right they may have perfectly fine jobs
and you know are able to pay their bills
and whatnot but there's a deep-seated
sense of dissatisfaction or a lack of
agency I think alienation that is at a
low boil and so you can continue to live
your life and it seems manageable and
not at some kind of acute crisis level
but it's just beneath the surface and
all it takes is something like this that
gives them permission to express it so
it's like a man versus machine feeling
like you feel like you're being ground
up by the machine by the way life is all
the structures are kind of being put
upon you and then ironically your
salvation is diving into this machine a
I machine and I and what a trip that is
I mean but I agree with you like there
is a there is something where people are
deeply unsatisfied I feel like it's an
alienation do you feel like it's more
exacerbated with that with quarantine
that it's actually becoming easier to
see worse yeah yeah it's it's the
witch's brew of quarantine and all of
the political unrest like it's all of
these things are combining to create a
very unique situation in which this
repressed rage is finding you know it's
finding its expression in these
unhealthy ways it's a trip I'm yeah it's
like the the the idea with coronavirus
and how some people's answer don't wear
masks we should go for herd immunity and
it'll be interesting to see when there
is a vaccine
how many of these people who claim they
want hurt immunity well line up for a
shot of herd immunity see the other
thing about rabbit hole that's
fascinating is it's not just about this
young man and his journey through the
YouTube algorithm yeah it then looks at
the origins of queuing on and you hear
testimony from these you know queue and
on people and how much they loved it
started out as like this community for
what sounded like people who are lonely
and they really enjoyed chatting with
you exactly what you're talking about
and that there's something healthy about
that but of course it's all you know
premise tap on this cue and on and hue
you got it we know we don't know I don't
know but how that then metastasize into
something unhealthy right the origins of
that were people getting together who
were able to chat with each other online
you know on reddit I guess well yeah but
they were chatting with each other about
how [ __ ] up the you know the system
was well that goes back to the
disenfranchisement right the the lack of
agency the feeling that you don't have
power over your life and when you can
point your finger at something else
outside of yourself and say that's why
and you can rally a lot of emotional
support around that that becomes a very
potent and powerful force it's
interesting because the two people that
that they profiled but first the YouTube
algorithm with the the younger guy in
West Virginia who was living at his
grandparents and who became a youtuber
himself right and then the woman who was
in the hospitality industry and she lost
everything in the financial crisis and
then had her home destroyed in hurricane
Irma and she got into the cocoon on
rabbit hole they both represent kind of
parallel to the opioid epidemic it's
it's hitting like it is hitting
disproportionately white communities
where there is this this kind of storm
of disempowerment coming through like a
guy coming out of college who like
dropped out of college couldn't figure
out what he was wanting to do
you didn't really have a lot of
opportunity living in his grandma's
house this woman who had hit a couple of
brick walls and financially and is now
living at some friends house with
nothing to do and no job it's it's those
are the people that are heading there so
there is I wonder what you think that if
there is from an addiction standpoint do
you see parallels Drive you know true in
this connection you're talking about
they're going for it's around a very
specific thing that they're kind of
tapping into well certainly you know I'm
not a psychologist but I think what is
going on is there is once you stumble
upon an idea that connects with you like
you see this person and they feel like
they're speaking to you directly and
they're telling you about your problems
and they're offering a solution right
that's very intoxicating and then you
can click on another video and this
person's going to tell you even more
something is going on biochemically in
your brain and as you begin to calcify
around these ideas then it becomes a
quest for confirmation bias you're gonna
click on more and more videos that are
going to affirm and entrench that
perspective and that's not a left or
right thing this is happening on both
polarities of both sides the spectrum
yeah and there's like something
happening in these videos that is very
extreme there's like the more extreme
you get the mo Outland as she gets the
bigger it gets like look at booty pie
right like right he this hundred and
that that's in the middle go through the
whole thing with him yeah and his growth
and how he's got a hundred million
subscribers I mean who's really the
alternative media now yeah yeah it's
interesting it that still gets pegged as
alternative media and yet that person
flicks on a video camera and is reaching
way more people than any television show
the URI Times has four million
subscribers we've got a hundred and
thirty million Joe wrote million well
that's what's so interested in like you
look at Rogan and I've said this many
times before but for a lot of people
especially young men he's the most
important media figure in their life no
doubt about 100
yeah incredibly influential and powerful
and despite a couple articles about him
and his show and his sort of universe of
people that he likes to have on in the
New York Times the Atlantic there's been
a couple pieces about it he doesn't it
doesn't come up in mainstream media it's
as if it doesn't exist in his what he's
doing is reaching more people than those
Sunday morning political you know
batshit political shows where everyone's
yelling at each other but you know it's
it's as ignorant as I was of pootie pies
Fame like I heard of him but I realized
how big he was and of you know how how
many like how mainstream actually this
YouTube stuff is like it is very
mainstream I did know about Rogan and
how dominant he was because obviously
with the David Goggins book my
experience and knowing how what a
dominant force he was but when Bernie
Sanders went on there he was killed on
Twitter on the left for like going on
Joe Rogan show it was I thought that was
insane that was insane because if you
know anything you know that's the
perfect place right to go you know like
if you want to actually if you want to
win recruit people who are potentially
Trump supporters to switch sides you get
Joe Rogan to endorse your candidate yes
that was the greatest thing that ever
happened and the fact that the left
railed against that I think shines a
light on it really elucidates
the systemic problems with the left at
the moment also the lack of
understanding of who's actually in
charge who's powerful and media right
now like there's a lack of understanding
like my lack of understanding was not
realizing you know pudy pie and all this
this crazy you know kuhn on and all III
really until I listened to this I didn't
really fully understand the depth of it
I just happen to know about I know about
Rogan but like there's a whole bunch of
people that don't realize it I remember
having debates with it on Twitter people
are trashing Bernie for going on Rogan
I'm like no they like that's the best
place to go right like yeah like that's
that makes perfect so I can tell you I
a guest on Joe show twice both of those
experiences were fantastic I get along
with Joe perfectly fine I have a huge
amount of respect for what he does and
when you go on his show and look the
last time I did it it was quite a long
time ago it's grown significantly since
then but it's insane
like the the spike in people that are
suddenly paying attention to you is
bananas unlike any other media I have
ever done a hundredfold yeah and I would
suspect that Dave Goggins would tell you
the same he's one of the most popular
guests that Joe's ever had on no doubt
no doubt like his his numbers spiked
significantly after that Joe Rogan abit
nothing has even touched it yeah nothing
even comes close
no it's incredibly powerful and people
now I think are more increasingly aware
that at least it exists but I still
think they're woefully underappreciated
the heft and the power that that program
holds at the moment agreed and it's and
the good thing about his program which
doesn't get I don't think a lot of
mainstream ink either is that he's
actually very smart he's the kind of
person you actually want a nice position
and he's very cagey in that he will say
look I'm just a dummy don't look at me
but he's very good at what he does and I
can tell you that as somebody who sat
across from him for six hours talking to
him there you go so did you want to get
into how the where the cue nun went or
do you want to get into cosmic ping-pong
or not really
now let's I think we're will do we'll
save that for another time could
monopolize hours of conversation and I
don't want to do that you know
lightly no yeah but you could take a
highlight and then all of a sudden that
could be in the queue I think you on
YouTube and think of all the although
here at yours you'll get I'm not doing
this for quick date now I think one I
will say this and then what let's move
on and that is that these are not
academic problems these are actual
issues that have real-world
ramifications and there is no more
example that illustrates that better
than
happen at cosmic pizza yeah when that
gunman showed up convinced that there
was a child sex ring going on in the
basement of this pizza parlor in
Washington DC and he in his own mind was
well intentioned he thought children
were being harmed because of the way
that he had been radicalized online and
and what you just said there shows how
we should approach this like it's
empathetic and that's how Kevin Roos
approaches it on this in this series and
it also is that that YouTube video I
referenced and I'll send you the link is
you should see this this this woman who
everyone on online was calling crazy and
look at her and haha what a joke she is
for a railing at this this City Council
Kevin put that up and said these issue
the the this is very mainstream it's not
fringe literally a hundred million
people could feel like he I don't forget
what his words were but look what she is
saying is not fringe and that's the
problem right what she is saying is
actually mainstream just like we're
talking about what is mainstream and the
solution and which is which is what
Kevin did such a good job of portraying
the solution is that we have to
understand what's going on with these
people that would lead to this kind of
that this kind of wrongheaded thinking
right like this is a person who was
vulnerable for these reasons and until
we address the situation that creates
that vulnerability this is only gonna
get worse well I think that's a good way
to kind of segue into how to feed the
soul in these trying times yes and if
it's not gonna be a yoga and meditation
rich I think it should be queer I it
should be that's where our good I mean
we have a couple choices here we have
queer I and we have Kanye let's go to
her I first these right these are our
chances for redemption here so we were
joking recently I think I was with you
and I just brought it up then you were
watching it but basically you
so throughout quarantine we have all our
kids home we've been having family
dinners there's a lot that's been really
nice about it and one of the things that
we've done not every night but like a
couple nights a week like after dinner
we're like alright what do you want to
watch and for some reason we started
watching queer I
my relationship with queer I dates back
to Queer Eye for the straight guy like
the original cast all the way back to me
and I had no I'm late to the party here
cuz I've never seen this television show
I think maybe I had a vague notion that
they had rebooted it and it existed but
I'd never watched an episode
he'd never watched it season 5 got
released yes spin around for five years
I've never seen it so this is like my
big like here's what everyone should
watch that everyone's like yeah I know
I've been watching that all along yeah
but I was really moved yeah by this
program like from the first episode that
I wash I'm like okay they're gonna it's
a makeover show these these do who are
these guys like they're gonna come and
they're gonna make these people over
without fail every episode of this show
that I've watched has been like an
emotional roller coaster it's so
inspiring yes I'm really touched by what
these five guys the way in which these
five guys are able to connect with so
many different varieties of humanity and
more than that the way in which they're
doing it I think it's really beautiful
and so over the course of the quarantine
we've watched the entire five seasons
I've missed a few nights you mentioned
one episode to me that's one of your
favorites I know the guy seen it yet but
the barbecue I love this show incredible
I've been on it since it started you
know like so Queer Eye for the straight
guy for those who have not seen the
original it was really all about getting
straight guys to look better and groom
better and live better and it was that's
what it was about and they were mostly
young it was MTV show I think I think so
yeah originally it was for young people
this they not only do they choose a
diverse cast of people who are
multi-talented and extremely good on
television and it's an hour long but
it's kind of adds a home-improvement
element that was like it flexes out the
home-improvement at tiptoe
it also bobby's a genius by the way yes
what he's able to do in five days
most people's homes is unbelievable and
then we have this is my hat tip to tan
France yeah wearing my tan France
approved sure looks good I think he
would approve and beauty with your
popular - I think hey listen I started
wearing a jacket on this podcast when I
started watching queer eyes so there you
go but they also chose like it's not
just men you know it's it's women it's
it's queer people it's people who are
like even on the gender spectrum mm-hmm
it's it's real hard cases like kind of
people that you wouldn't expect right
this group of gay men to go into and
help and it's there's a whole season in
the south in Georgia and where they're
interacting with all kinds of people who
for the most part a lot of them I think
really had no meaningful relationships
with any gay people in their lives ever
before yeah and the compassion and the
patience and the fun that they bring
into these people's lives is I mean I
just I think in the love ya self-love
right and and just that's the other huge
difference between that original version
in this one is the self-help empowerment
angle that Kurama brings and they say
he's like chromo culture he's not called
this guy is like literally helping these
people see their lives with more clarity
identifying the the the obstacles that
they're facing or what's hamstringing
them and trying to help them find a
better path forward
I mean culture came from the original I
think like one person's job was to teach
them how to eat properly and like to go
dancing and these kinds of things and so
they that's what they tagged krama with
the chromo is a guy who is I think a
licensed clinical social worker like a
therapist like a therapist yeah and he
is I mean he will just cut right to the
core every time right yeah I got a
favorite I got to get that guy on the
podcast I know he has his own podcast on
luminary he did I think Russell Brand
had Kurama on his show I'm gonna check
that out I gotta listen um yeah I I got
it I mean that's got to happen
kurama's got to get on the show and what
about JBL jvn I mean has there ever it I
mean what do you even say I mean the guy
is like I don't know what they're paying
that guy but they should like triple it
I mean he's the most fabulous
entertaining unique human being you're
ever gonna see on television yeah he's
beautiful
he played Carnegie Hall by the way did
he yeah you didn't know that see I don't
know any I don't know any did like a
whole like comedy variety show with
gymnastics and he played Carnegie Hall I
saw him do the splits did you see it I
knew that he was like a cheerleader in
his high school did you go did you watch
the episode where he went back to his
high school and and queer I'd like the
woman who was in charge of all I started
watching it and then I had to work and I
missed it so that's another one you had
to go back a whole party yes like JB
yeah yeah I mean that guy is
unbelievable
and how he connects with people like
with his childlike nature you know it's
so warm and inviting yeah those guys are
doing more for gay rights I mean the
advocacy that's kind of behind like it's
it's not explicit it's sort of just
they're on the way that they carry
themselves I think it's really powerful
they're just yeah beautiful human being
smart on top of it together and and and
empathetic right like they're looking
for the places that no matter who it is
they're yeah they're always they're not
they're not spending any time on the
differences or the division they're
going right towards what they can
connect with like what are the
similarities where's the what is the way
in with this person how can I relate to
them yeah it's cool so I'm five on five
years late to this party but you're in
the body anybody's listening to this or
watching this and they're like me I have
been enjoying it and I here's the the
final part of the show and tell which is
like the cherry on top of this Sunday is
I'm scrolling through Twitter the other
day and Brene brown posted this thing
that I thought so great I love brené
Brown she's another person I
really want to get on the show she's
magnificent apparently she was hiking in
the Texas Hill Country right she lives
in Houston right so yeah she's more
around Austin it is around us but it
sounded like she was out in the middle
of nowhere but it's all still eastern
Texas right Austin
I used to there yeah yeah she's out
hiking by herself in the middle of
nowhere and she stumbles upon somebody
sitting under a cedar tree and it turns
out it's JV ed she's like and they both
say apparently according to retreat they
both say oh my god is at you because I
guess they were supposed to do an event
yes yes so I don't know just it warms my
heart to think those two discovered each
other on a trail and how to hike
together it's great it's radical radical
love and Jeannie Ann is it's bit of a
radical I like it yeah like politics he
I don't know much about his politics he
had a yeah he's all about he's all about
the right thing it just puts a smile on
my face that those two would be out
together and I think we need a little
bit of good news
amidst all we do that's right that's
what it's all about there's there was
that was kind of your win of the week
right we were doing that was my win of
the was your one day the Brene brown jvn
Union that's a win that is a win yeah do
you have a win yeah my win was was the
Argentinian who wanted to get back to
his 90 year old dad and couldn't fly
home because he was stuck in Portugal
and there were no flights back into
Buenos Aires and he had a 29 foot boat
and he decided to sail home for his
dad's birthday and was at sea for 89
days he tried to resupply in Cape Verde
the islands off of you know West Africa
mhm and they wouldn't take him because
they're a small island nation and they
they were careful about the virus and he
sailed across the Atlantic all the way
down to Mar del Plata which is this
incredible fishing city in Argentina and
he sailed all the way home to see his
dad he didn't make his birthday
but he he got there and a great story
beautiful yeah trying to think of what I
would do for my time well that is I mean
wow that hit home because my dad has
been having some health issues yeah you
know the hospital so for me it's like to
see that and just and he had you know
the the the Sailor I'm sorry I'm spaced
on his name but we'll put the link to
the story in the shownotes right yeah so
people were sure he didn't get and get
it was New York Times story time story
and he you know just to see his own
personal growth on that he was by
himself for that entire time he like
didn't even fish she couldn't kill
anything he still ate his like canned
tuna but like he had he's like he's not
gonna fish anymore he just had this Wow
he went through his own you know
crucible how did he if he wasn't able to
resupply he is stored I mean he
obviously boats like that will have a
desalinator
and then he he had stored a bunch of
canned tuna use mostly that was this
thing off hand tuna and whatever else he
brought along and no gas because he
couldn't get gas at Cape Verde so he was
just like dealing Whittle drums and
trying to find the wind and trying to
stay safe and amazing good deal well I
feel better it's good yeah good
so we answer some listener emails well
let's take a quick break and then we'll
come back and do a little listener email
let's do it and we're back what do you
got for me Adam okay before we get into
listener email I have my own my I'm a
listener yeah my own question okay
because I know you went to the Sunday
service something is it called Sunday
service Sunday Kanye Kanye is doing and
I never really asked you about it but
now since Kanye is right gasps you see
it's you never know like what is this
real is he running for president is this
a stunt right does he just have a record
Jimin Elon Musk we're together the other
day and Ilan's on board with this yes
who knows vice president
I don't need be vice president maybe
secretary state like Henry Kissinger had
to be like Secretary of State or
something cuz he wasn't born here I'm
telling you we live in a simulation this
is good crazy it's becoming what it's
becoming The Watchmen yeah only if Kanye
wins will we be at the Watchmen but you
know it's good so just a little
background we don't know if he's running
because in order to run you have to get
signatures and get on the ballot and
different-style blah blah who cares belt
up and he's already still he's already
not he's already missed the deadline but
there's more there's there's more
deadlines coming let's just take a bead
on that until we get a sense of what's
actually real yeah let's do that but but
tell us your story about going to the
service because what is he is he a pop
star spiritual leader what is Kanye I
think Kanye divides definition doesn't
he he does he said he's a he's you know
he's he's basically a cultural icon
mm-hmm is there anybody who has who
wields more cultural influence than
Kanye West I don't know
Beyonce maybe I don't know not not very
many people I mean it's unbelievable the
influence that that guy has had not just
on music but on culture or fashion a
whole variety yeah subject man maybe his
wife and he he he lives not too far from
me and I remember when he first started
doing the Sunday service thing and I
thought that's sort of cool like wow
like he's doing I thought it was like in
his backyard or something like that
right and I was out running on a trail
near my house not long after I heard
about that for the first time and I
started to hear gospel music and I
realized oh my goodness this is this is
where it's at it's like it's happening
in it was a Sunday morning and I ran
they they had like all kinds of security
you couldn't get too close to it but I
could see from a distance like oh that
is the thing and they're all these
people there and I remember thinking I
got to figure out how to get in on this
like I want to be able I want to get
invited I want to see I want to witness
this experience right because this is
really interesting and unique and
everyone's dressed in white right
everyone's wearing white they're all
there's there's music happening it
didn't look like it there were that
many people in attendance probably just
his friends and his family and I just
remember thinking not only am I do I
wanna figure out how to be invited to
this to see it I'm gonna this is gonna
happen like yes it was a weird there's
no reai don't know Kanye like I've know
in or anything like that I just thought
somehow that's gonna happen and it did
happen and the way that it happened is
that our friend Mel na Haas I I was like
out running and I posted an Instagram
story and I was like hey you can hear
the music like this is my trail like you
could kind of I just shared it and she
saw that and texted me and she's like
where is that exactly like I want to
know exactly where that's happening and
I I just like dropped a pin on a map and
I sent it to her she's like I'm gonna
have my birthday party on that little
piece of that little mound of dirt out
on that trail it's like good luck
figuring out how to make that out like
how do you even get a permit like who do
you even call just like don't worry
about it like she produces all her
retreats you know she she's amazing like
she knows how to figure this stuff out
and sure enough she knew a park ranger
and sorted it out and got the permission
to be able to host like an evening
dinner party like out in the middle of
this field on this thing and on this
state owned Nature Preserve basically so
we go to this dinner and there's you
know I don't know 30 or 40 people there
and it's caterer it's beautiful the
sun's setting it's a lovely evening and
we're enjoying ourselves and we're of
course all talking about like this is
actually where this Sunday service thing
is going on you know how loud is that
like I wonder what he's gonna do with it
and we're all just it's the topic of
conversation naturally and in the
distance I see a guy walking up with two
little kids like way out you could too
far away to identify but dark-complected
and I'd remember joking to it to Julian
mal is like oh there's Kanye he's gonna
come over and see how we're doing
come on and as he got nearer and nearer
I was like actually kind of looks like
huh and and then he just walked right up
to our group and I was like oh my god
that's Kanye West he's like coming to
your
birthday party like how about that so I
was like come on we got to go over and
talk to him he was on the other side of
that like the where the dinner was
happening so Julie and I walk over and
he's talking he starts talking to Mel
and he's with his daughter and his
daughter's friend and they had just
walked up he lives nearby and he just
walked up to his he put these boulders
around the perimeter of it and his kids
wanted to play daughter wanted to play
on that so he just came up for no reason
just by himself and he's like what's
going on here and we explained to him
and and it was wild like he was like oh
that's cool like he wanted to know who
we were
he was very genuine grounded presence
gracious kind like it was a very cool
experience it just caught on and that
was that and then he and then we were
and we kind of I was like alright we
gotta ask if we can come with the thing
right so like drop it and he's like
here's the number of you know my
assistant or whatever like she'll hook
it up and then sure enough like we were
able to go the following Sunday so Julie
and I and Mel went to the thing and it
was wild you know it was what happens is
you start with a sermon or you know you
drive up you you would drive up to this
like sort of staging parking lot that
would still maybe a half mile away from
the actual site and they have all kinds
of people and all the white you know and
then they're like this way and they're
kind of guiding you and what direction
to go and and then you just congregate
in a circle around this they he had
built up this mound like in the middle
where the choir would went up there all
the musicians where they were performing
and there were probably I don't know
maybe less than a hundred people in
attendance to watch hmm and it had
really nothing to do with Kanye he
didn't make himself really a part he was
participating but it wasn't like the
Kanye show it was all about this choir
and these musicians he put the music
together though right I'm sure he came
up with you know the whole program yeah
but it wasn't like oh he's gonna get on
the Mike and he's gonna talk like it was
none of that like he was very much you
the background is sleeping no no nobody
really there was a choir director and
there was very little talking it was
really just music so it's like the old
House of Blues like Sunday brunch with
gospel but without the the I don't know
ever went to that so I don't know what
what that's like
and it went on for maybe an hour an hour
and a half and it was cool awesome [ __ ]
it was really lovely great music and it
was wild like I was like oh I think
that's Brad Pitt over there no way come
on there are definitely some interesting
people there you know but and that was
it like then I mean I don't know so what
another thing that was interesting about
that is that then I kind of shared a
couple pictures on Instagram about how
much I enjoyed that and you know people
were there were a lot of people that
gave me [ __ ] for that because he's a
polarizing always a polarizing he's
boring you know he had worn the the
maggot hat and the whole thing and so
for that he'd worn the magnet I think so
I think so and I was just there to
experience this creative expression that
I thought was kind of an amazing thing
that seems what's most important to him
is like right creative freedom and
creative well I think I think there is a
courage and a fearlessness in his
creative expression because he he's not
he's constantly iterating right he's
never stuck in any particular lane and
the minute you try to define him he
pivots and does something completely
different
yeah and I think there's a lot to be
learned from that in you know in it and
it begins with the the way in which he
created his music and how that
juxtaposed juxtaposing that against
current trends and hip-hop at the time
like he's always been an innovator
did you see the was a GQ they did a
spread on his like Montana ranch and
like no plans that he has to these
architectural plans for what he wants to
do with this property it's like it's
it's wild why doesn't every rich guy
have a Montana I don't I don't know you
don't hear of like women maybe it's
Wyoming I'm like Reese Witherspoon
doesn't have a Montana right it's always
guys with their Montana ranch
I guess Reese Witherspoon's Montana
ranch
yeah he'll ever she probably is a red
sorry so that's the big Kanye story make
of it what you will
I like the Kanye's story um I hope he's
not running for president personally I
don't think that would be good for our
army all right let's get into John
Brown's question it's interesting
because it gets to kind of stuff that we
were talking about just in terms of
personal paralysis and satisfaction or
dissatisfaction I'm 44 with a wife and
three kids and I want so badly to take a
bold step into the unknown what advice
would you give me if I cornered you at a
coffee shop one morning hey John I'm
sympathetic to that question although I
have very few facts to go on here in
order to answer this I think the first
thing I would say is why a bold step
like what's going on in your life right
now where you feel compelled to not just
make a change but make a bold change and
I think you need to answer that for
yourself first right like what is what's
the discontent or the the I don't know
what would it call what would you call
it like that
the lack of groundedness that the that
gives you that kind of anxiousness yes
that's why it intends to status right
yeah like oh yeah that's what I see in
that like why does it have to be bold so
understanding that I think it's the
first step to trying to figure out what
to do next you have three kids you have
a wife you're 44 I don't know what your
occupation is I don't know what your
satisfaction with your occupation is I
don't know if this bold step that you
want to make is professional or personal
so that makes it challenging to answer
this but I think I would I would presume
you're meaning professional when you
have three kids and a wife I would
caution you from being too bold I think
that it's romantic
this idea of quitting your job and you
know sailing to Argentina with cans of
tuna right in your boat or something
like that I know but I'm just saying
like if you're feeling stuck like that
you can romance
sighs these other paths for yourself
without fully thinking them through yeah
so short of a bold step my suggestion to
you would be what can you do right now
that doesn't require you to burn your
life down to the ground right like
whether it's a side hustle or just
finding something that brings you
happiness that you can lend greater
expression to your daily life would be
the place to start just because you're
you have something in your life that's
not functioning properly doesn't mean
that you have to cast aside everything
else and and and do something super
drastic you know you know there is a
pragmatism to all of this because those
bold steps although sexy have
ramifications for the other people in
your life and of course you have to
think all of that through so the advice
that I would give you if you cornered me
in a coffee shop would first be a bunch
of questions I would need answered in
order to give you that advice but I
think it begins with being intentional
about how you're spending your time on a
daily basis and having the mindfulness
to carve out sections of your day every
single day that are just for you where
you can invest in that one thing that
one activity that one practice that can
bring you a little bit more joy and also
perhaps be a stepping stone towards that
bold step that you can take at a later
time I love it and I think that
mindfulness thing that you're
referencing it kind of gets us into the
next question the question was from John
Pierce tell us about some of your
mentors but you hadn't really we don't
want to go there so I think a better
question is what about you talk about
mindfulness a lot so my question for you
kind of piggybacked off John's question
would be kind of can you describe your
mindfulness practice and and how did you
get into it was there a spiritual mentor
or someone that kind of guided you into
mindfulness mmm well I would start by
saying that my mindfulness practice is
far from perfect and I say that not only
as a reminder to myself that I can
improve tremendous
Leon what I'm currently doing but also
because I think people think of
mindfulness practices as some sort of
standard that's hard to live up to hmm
we quantify it and then say it has to
look like this and if you're not doing
this then you're falling short and when
people feel like they can't do that or
they fall off a program then they
abandon the practice all together the
first thing I would do is define what is
mindfulness practice mean it can be
formal meditation but mindfulness is
broader than that in the sense that it's
something that we can be doing at all
times like how can I be more mindful in
this moment so that I can impart the
best piece of advice that I'm capable of
giving well it means that I have to be
present it means that I have to ground
myself and take a breath and calm my
disposition enough so that what I'm
expressing is done with clarity and
purpose hmm so we could be in a
mindfulness practice right now
mindfulness does not necessitate formal
meditation per se but mindfulness is
certainly a byproduct of a formal
meditation practice
so my mindfulness practice involves a
combination of formality and informality
I do have a formal meditation practice
that I do every morning for 20 minutes I
shouldn't say every morning because it's
not every morning right I'm catching
myself in that but the goal is every
more fit goal is every morning and I
know most and I fall short of that all
the time so the key with that is if you
miss a day not to throw the baby out
with the bathwater but just to start
again the next day whenever you have it
or if you have five minutes or if you
have two minutes or if you have time for
one inhale and one exhale that can be a
mindfulness practice
then it's about a constant process of
reminding myself throughout the day to
be more present in whatever it is that
I'm doing left to my own devices I'm
running all kinds of scenarios I'm busy
I'm running all kinds of scenarios I
should've said that why did I call that
guy back I got to do that thing that
person let me down I owe that person a
phone call this guy was supposed to get
back to me and he didn't you know the
drill right so how can I just let go of
that and be present and often that's
with paying attention to my breath and
also just that gentle reminder like oh
I'm doing that thing let's come back to
now let's come back to now let's come
back to now you think after a while you
wouldn't have to do that anymore
maybe that's true for you not for me but
I will say the more rigorous I am in my
daily formal meditation practice the
easier it is to be mindful throughout
the day mm-hmm the half-life of that
meditation practice is longer and
conversely the half-life of my varying
emotional states is shorter so if I get
angry I can get back to baseline more
quickly if I'm frustrated a quick
reminder and I'm back to baseline and I
think that's the real flex that you get
when you build that muscle it's not that
you you become some Buddha like
individual it's that you're more self
aware of when your emotions are running
you rather than the other way around and
you developed a facility to resume a
state of equanimity hmm you asked who
the mentors are for this I mean you know
I've I've sat with gurus and I've spent
time on meditation apps so there isn't
one person that I can speak to and I
think it's important to not over
complicate these things if all you're
doing is sitting down for five minutes
and you're paying attention to your
breath and you're inhaling and exhaling
that's really all you need to know you
can go on your own journey to learn more
about all of these
specific techniques and find what
resonates for you but I'm reticent to
like say this is the mentor this is the
person that you should follow the
traditions very there's some yeah of
course the traditions vary depending but
do you do you is it silent meditation
for you oh yes mantra at all no I don't
yeah I'm not trying I'm not trained in
TM so I don't have a mantra it's a
silent breath practice and I would say
in addition to that training is an
active meditation for me so if I'm out
on the trail if I'm riding my bike
that's a mindfulness practice and what I
would call an active meditation but it's
important to point out that that is not
a formal meditation practice and I think
there's a lot of confusion there a lot
of people think well I don't sit down
and Lotus position and meditate and I'm
not saying anybody has to sit in lotus
position but going out for a run even if
you're not wearing headphones is not the
same as a formal meditation practice
those it has value but it's a
qualitatively different experience and
that's something I had to learn because
I used to think that I didn't need a
formal practice because I go and spend
all this time alone out in nature that's
good enough but I can tell you from my
own experience that the difference in
how I feel and how I behave and how I
interact with other people and the
vicissitudes of my emotional state are
much better when I'm engaged in that
formal meditation practice the active
meditation aspect of it is a is a sort
of cousin that adds additional benefit
but not at the expense of the more
formal practice so you just pop out of
the tent on the roof and just fold right
into the lotus position and go I make
some coffee or I make a tea and then I
and then I do it no yoga first no no now
I try to I try to do the meditation
first first thing before anything
because it also because if I don't do it
right then it becomes less and less
likely that it's gonna happen so it's
got to be the first thing okay yeah and
then I will journal a little bit I do
morning page
is from the artists way okay and then I
either go out and train or I use the
time for creative pursuits like this
book right now so I'm actually not
training very much at all because I'm on
such crazy deadlines when do you watch
you're keen on videos is that like after
lunch yes my first thing right away good
you dive right in when you're maximally
receptive yeah as ideas I have research
to do so I gotta carve out like seven to
ten hours you have done your research my
friend Laurie Marvis who is the one
person you have yet to interview that is
at the top of your list and I guess
we've already said Kurama and burn a
brown so maybe got it well yeah those
are two that I was like get it's funny I
I don't have like some crazy list like
that I mean I'd love to get Eckhart
Tolle on he would be great who wouldn't
want the rock I mean I mean come on
right like so we can talk about people
like that but it's similar to people
always ask me like who you know what's
your five-year plan or what's the goal
what's the big thing you're worth it's
like I don't I've just never been wired
like that I'm really much more in the
moment like I'm just kind of feeling
what's next so my line of vision isn't
lasered on or rooted in like I have to
get this person like I I have a
spreadsheet open where I have I just put
names on as they pop into my head or
somebody like oh that would be cool so I
don't forget but it's not like I'm
driving towards any one particular
person I probably should have an answer
to that question but I don't know buddy
okay yeah moving on we'll see who shows
up I'm trusting in the universe Adam to
devour me the best people huh huh but we
don't know about that algorithm
[Laughter]
algorithm in my head that's deciding if
you motivate the algorithm within it
shall be delivered Anna Nicole no Anna
Nicole how to find your own purpose I've
been living a very comfortable life up
to now but have really lost motivation
to work or take care of responsibilities
everything is hard because I'm dragging
my feet and waiting to the last minute
to complete how does
one find their groove again or a sense
of purpose when they don't even know
what they want
I know it's vague but it's how it rolls
around in my head I think this one is
the reason I put this in the list is
because I know a lot of people are
struggling with quarantine I know you
we've talked about even your own family
and issues that with quarantine just
like how it's challenging for so many
people so I think that that would be a
good one to kind of in context of the
moment we're in now well I think Anna's
question is something that everybody can
relate to on some level right we're all
looking for greater purpose in our lives
and we're all evaluating how we're
living on a day to day basis against
some standard imagined or otherwise of
what our life could look like so it's
easy to say my life's not working I
should have this why am I not super
excited when I wake up in the morning
when I read this question I think what's
instructive is first of all the fact
that she says she's living a very
comfortable life right so there's almost
like some guilt like my life's been
comfortable so I shouldn't complain
right like I shouldn't I should just be
happy with what I have right but at the
same time if you're dragging your feet
if you're procrastinating there's
something that's perhaps a little bit
out of function at the moment so the
first question I would ask is what isn't
working like perhaps do an inventory of
what's sub-optimal and try to set aside
that guilt like you feel like it's
indulgent for me because I live a
comfortable life to make a list of
things that aren't working because I'm
lucky and great I'm grateful to have the
job that I have or the apartment that I
live in or whatever it is but if you can
be rigorous and objective in that
inventory of what's not working
optimally I think that's a starting
place and then the elusive ever elusive
question of like how do you find purpose
how do you go back how do you or if
you've lost it how do you get back and I
wish I could give you a pity answer of
here's how you do it it's very difficult
right this is a
an individual journey that's gonna look
different for everybody but I think
fundamentally for everybody it begins
with an inside job like this is an
internal search right if you don't know
what your purpose is I can't tell you
what your purpose is you have to
discover that for yourself and that
journey of self-discovery requires you
to look inward also in a rigorous and
objective way to try to figure out what
it what what it is about who you are
that a makes you uniquely you and B that
you feel inspired to uniquely Express
and the only way of answering that
question or unlocking it is to not only
ask yourself those questions but to
begin experimenting right like try these
different things what do you what brings
you joy try to remember that thing when
you were a kid that you used to like to
do not because somebody told you to do
it but because you had a natural
inclination towards it as we grow older
we tend to let go of those things or we
shift our our perspective on them and
decide that they are the purview of a
young person and as a responsible adult
it's no longer okay for you to engage in
those things so the more that you can
connect with that inner child I think
and try to remember what some of those
behaviors and activities are and build
those back into your life I think is a
good means of connecting with yourself
that might lead you to some discoveries
around purpose and I also think that
[Music]
this can be indulgent
so rather than flogging yourself like
what is my purpose and I need a purpose
maybe just go help somebody else out
yeah you know the more that you can get
out of your own way and your own self
obsession and just make yourself
available to somebody who has less than
you and it doesn't mean that you have to
go volunteer at a soup kitchen although
that's perfectly fine it could be
calling up
a friend that you haven't talked to in a
long time or somebody that you know is
having a hard time and just letting them
know that you're available to them and I
think when you build that into a habit
where being of service to other people
in a selfless way is a reflex rather
than a burden or an obligation that in
my experience and what I've seen with
other people is probably the best way to
set you on a trajectory that's going to
connect you with some kind of purpose in
your life I know for myself when I'm of
service to other people my problems
don't matter or they get smaller and the
truth is when you're the more selfless
you are first of all the happier the
happier you are it's very gratifying
when you're helping other people like it
gives your life meaning so if when I say
how do I find purpose what I hear is
like my life doesn't feel like it has
meaning well everybody can build more
meaning into their life by helping other
people your life immediately becomes
more meaningful when you're of service
to others how do you groove back be of
service to others mm I love that
that's great and experimenting you can
even do on a daily basis you can't find
your purpose maybe your purpose with a
capital P on a daily basis but like I
remember I was in New York with my
friend Anthony Denby a long time ago and
he I woke up I was staying with him and
he's like what's your purpose today
what's your intention today hmm and and
I never do that you know I got the
specific attention and I felt kind of
like simultaneously like wow what am I
doing wrong
and then also okay I decided connection
you know connection connect um and later
that day I was on this subway that got
stopped in the middle of like the track
for 25 minutes and people were losing
their minds because they were busy or
whatever and this will guy next to me
was like cursing and freaking out and I
instead of like just leap like I started
to talk to him uh-huh because that was
an intention and that's like what you're
saying with experimenting you can start
that easy if you don't know where to
volunteer just yet or who to be of
service to right didn't wake up and give
yourself a purpose every morning what's
today's per
this yeah and it can be what I love
about that story is if you decided that
day your intention was was connection
and you're stuck on that subway that
just means to engage that dude who's
having a hard time on the subway and
maybe make his day a little bit better
that's it yeah man just talked with him
and talk through his problem and that's
what we did yeah yeah meanwhile there
was this weird like six-foot-five
skinhead that was making like figure
Eight's in the hall like stomping in his
combat boots that you didn't want to
look at that was scary that guy all
right New York City question five
Bryant Olander asks what's up Brian
here's a subject that may be at the
heart of the Great Divide we are seeing
getting wider in America cognitive
dissonance two people looking at the
same event and walking away with
extremely opposite opinions I'd love to
hear your thoughts
well this relates directly to what we've
already been talking about yeah listen
to rabbit hole and it basically goes
down a rabbit hole of how we've arrived
at this place I think there's a broader
conversation about confirmation bias and
cognitive dissonance you know and how
the brain works it is interesting that
that you know two different people could
watch the same news program and walk
away with completely different ideas
about it and then I think the the larger
problem is how entrenched we become in
those ideas such that when we're
presented with a counterfactual
narrative no matter how compelling that
narrative it it's irrelevant it doesn't
matter it's not going to move the needle
in terms of how that person is seeing
the world whether it's the Trump voter
who can't be talked out of voting for
Trump or the super liberal person who
you know sees the world in a specific
way the the idea that you're gonna
change these people's minds I think is
minoo we all know how difficult that is
and and what is that about right like
and I think it has a lot to do with
again to bring it back to the beginning
of this conversation disenfranchisement
and disempowerment as human beings were
hardwired to want to be part of a
community of a tribe and we align
ourselves with various teams whether
it's the Philadelphia Eagles or you know
the Los Angeles Lakers like look at
sports and how we try belies that
politics are a close cousin of that and
I think as as as swath of the population
become progressively more
disenfranchised there's a sense of lack
of control and I think there's an agency
that develops when somebody can latch on
to a certain tribe and craft an identity
around that right this is who I am
this is my identity and and you get
strength from that no matter who you are
like if you're in the Democratic Party
this is who I am this is what we stand
for this is our values and I'm going to
defend my my membership status in this
tribe against everything else no matter
what facts that I'm presented with so
then the question becomes how did we
become so susceptible to these silos
these tribes and why do we cling to them
so strongly and maybe it has something
to do with the fact that the connections
that we have in our own communities have
been fractured and this is taking the
place of that whether it's the church or
the 4-h club or whatever it is that in
the 1950s through the 70s people used to
do within their respective neighborhoods
a lot of that has gone away and we've
become suburban eyes and you know
cul-de-sac eyes to such an extent do
that we no longer yeah we no longer have
those connections that fabric that weds
us to our local communities doesn't
quite exist in the way that it used to
so as human beings we're finding other
ways of doing that so we are doing it
digitally
and and maybe because we don't have
those in person
tactile bonds that's why we're holding
on so tightly to the identities that we
fabricate that are based on ideologies
rather than proximity well you're
talking what we're talking about is
looking at something
everyone's watch it's watching the same
thing and coming away with different
opinions but the fact is we're not
watching the same thing right so that's
also part of it that's part of it yeah
yeah so we're watching different angles
of the same thing yeah and well there is
no there is no unified source of
quote/unquote truth anymore we're all
self selecting our information silos
we're all on different diets basically
also I think perception of
disenfranchisement interesting because
you know a lot of it is a perception
thing you know like where you perceive
yourself in the greater whole and when
you there's two ways of looking at
feeling small in this big world to me
the healthy view is I'm a small fragment
of this great web and I'm connected to
all of it and it's all part of me and
I'm part of it and there's this there's
a sense of responsibility that comes
with that and there's a sense of you
know humility that comes with that mmm
being the small thing speck in this you
know it's one pixel yeah in this in this
tapestry or this picture you're just a
couple zeros and ones yeah that's a
matrix as part of the what the great
algorithm that green stream of like
characters that's flowing down the
shangri-la algorithm but then the
negative view of that is why do I feel
so small in these [ __ ] are such big
shots you know and like what is
disenfranchisement like if you have a
place to live and some food on your
plate and you're comfortable and you're
warm or whatever like like how
disenfranchised should you actually feel
so it's like there's all these moving
parts to the modern world now and
there's always been this way and we
watched American Beauty
because we had to go back to the DVDs
because our cable company fumbled the
ball right on our move and so we were
watching that and there's a great scene
where the where what's the guy video you
know the the young Wes yes what's his
real name
no you mean yeah the classic scene of
them and he's his dad is like reading
the morning paper and he's like what's
going on dad and dad goes this country
is going straight to hell
it's basically always been that each
other these countries always been going
straight to hell like I'm sure in the
Revolution the day after the
Revolutionary War and there was like
someone complaining about it and every
generation is told that like oh it's
always been this way every generation
says that but and then they say yeah but
this time it really is appear so right
now maybe it is we can't end on that
note no but the point is is that there's
always that kind of like this
disenfranchisement is a point of view I
always think of it that way like we're
in charge of our emotional perspective I
mean don't you think I mean like isn't
that isn't that what you you're trying
to we try to kind of tell people and
tell them they're kids and tell
everybody is like that no one tells you
no one can tell you how you feel or how
you're gonna react to something you have
control over that yes that agency
resides within all of us and in a
culture and a world where we feel like
that that our agency has been stripped
from us it's important to realize that
there are still certain things that only
you have control over you can't control
the insanity of the chaotic world you
can't control what other people are
going to do you can't control the news
cycle all you can control is your
reaction to all of that and how you can
port yourself so it always goes back to
mindfulness the more mindful that you
can be the more a quantum Asst you can
carry yourself the better equipped you
are
to manage whatever problems you
encounter whether they be related to
disenfranchisement or your lack of sense
of control over your life always turn
back inward and as guru Singh always
says less emotion more devotion I love
that right like rather than getting all
emotional about things that you can't
control check yourself
what are you devoted to what are you
cultivating inside of yourself that can
lead to greater self awareness self
improvement all you can control is
yourself the path forward is to be the
best version of yourself so that you're
equipped to handle all those other
things that you cannot control and the
byproduct of that is you become a force
of harmony in this world and like
dissonant right dissonance and music is
a tool to be used to make people feel
and then it always wants to come back to
harmony like the piece of music always
wants to come back dissonance always
merges back so that's a better note to
end on yes it will if we if we cultivate
that yeah yeah agreed
yeah I think we did it all right ma'am
thanks for having me
episode 3 roll on I like being your hype
man it's good man how you feel you feel
good I feel good I liked it when you
read my resume though that's that really
oh I forgot to do that I know you don't
talk you because my wife reads me my
resignation yeah read it to you yeah but
sometimes you record it for you other
men's resumes that are a lot more
oppressive if she's pissed
Adam Skolnick co-author of can't hurt me
author of one breath one breath New York
Times yeah contributing writer
environmentalist activist and now audio
pontificate er just last night man yeah
audio pontificate er that's like the
podcast version of talking head right
audio pontificate er awesome you could
find Adam online you could see his is
digital ones in zero streaming across
the matrix at Adam Skolnick on Twitter
and Instagram don't forget to hit that
subscribe button on YouTube Apple or
Spotify thanks for listening and
watching everybody check the show notes
we're going to put links up to
everything that we talked about today
you can find that on the specific
episode page at rich roll comm and
generally on the youtube version we put
links up to stuff as well if you want to
contribute a question for us to consider
answering on this show you can do that
on our Facebook group yeah which is the
rich roll podcast on Facebook I'll put a
link up to that as well on YouTube and
the show notes also if you join the
Facebook group you can also I would be
great if you could contribute to that
survey that we've put up there as well
we should probably think about getting a
voicemail option like it for people like
yeah then we could like play their audio
like question instead well I am getting
a landline can I make you an assign yes
I can do that I think you need it like
you get that Google Voice these phone
numbers exist like I'll figure that out
alright I figure that out we'll try to
move forward with that and then up we'll
put up a new post for the questions so
we can have okay oh right yeah cool
awesome man so she back here with
another version of this in two weeks
until then be well appreciate you guys
thank you love see you back here a
couple days with another great episode I
love you peace plants
[Music]